though 2023 is set to be a pivotal year
for the US and its diplomacy President
Joe Biden has suggested he could meet
with Vladimir Putin if the Russian
president is looking for a way to end
the war in Ukraine there's also the
possibility of a presidential visit to
Northern Ireland but could that trip be
overshadowed by ongoing tensions between
Britain and the EU over brexit that's
where I started my conversation with the
U.S deputy secretary of state Wendy
Sherman
modern deputy secretary thank you for
being on Sky News for this uh trip to
London parts of Europe as well I wanted
to start off by asking you about
something that matters to us Brits and
also to the Americans next year we'll
mark the 25th anniversary of the Good
Friday agreement the president's due to
visit potentially Northern Ireland to
mark that moment how important is it
that the Northern Ireland protocol issue
is resolved by then I think we all want
to see the issue resolved President
Biden spoke with your new prime minister
and I think we all have optimism that an
agreement can be reached it's very
important from an American perspective
to reach an agreement and I think people
are working very hard to get there it's
terribly important and
back then then President Bill Clinton
who you know well uh closely was closely
involved in those negotiations to keep
talks going does President Biden stand
ready to get involved in the same way if
necessary I think America's always ready
to support the United Kingdom you know
we have a special relationship there's
no denying that I've started this trip
to the capitals of Europe and I began in
London
this is an incredibly Rich relationship
now we're sorry that we are not in the
final games of the football match and I
did mean to start by congratulating
England on its win against Senegal and
now coming into the finals I know it'll
be quite a match on Saturday and I can
tell you that Americans are now uh as we
say Soccer Crazy uh football crazy so
we'll be watching uh with eager eager
interest and I should say Madam the USA
4 surveillance fights as well and got
through to the qualifying stages getting
knocked out the other night but I have
to ask you now you've mentioned it on
the special relationship France versus
England who would you like to win
um whoever comes out first uh I think
it's going to be a tough match we were
very excited to get into the final
rounds and we have a young team I think
they'll come back the next time even
stronger and you know I had an event at
the state department on our eighth floor
which is our big rooms I even had a
soccer jersey that the U.S soccer team
gave me said Sherman won we invited all
the Diplomatic Corps had big screen TVs
there's just football Madness in the
United States as there is around the
world because I think Sports brings
people together so we're very excited to
watch on so it's a very diplomats
because you're of course going to Paris
next so
so maybe wise not to come out in favor
of England but my oscar afterwards uh
President Biden said last week he was
prepared to speak to Mr Putin if in fact
there was an interest in him deciding
he's looking for a way to end the war in
Ukraine he hasn't done that yet he went
on to say the only way for that to
happen would be for President Putin to
pull out of Ukraine number one what does
pull out mean does it mean the
withdrawal to from Crimea
I think that we have always said nothing
about Ukraine without Ukraine and the
United States and the United Kingdom
Great Britain have been side by side in
this effort
I'm really just so grateful for
everything that Britain has done to
support the ukrainians America as well
53 billion dollars to date in our
security assistance and additional
humanitarian support
so we have a lot ahead of us and what's
important here is there is one aggressor
and that's Vladimir Putin and one victim
and that's Ukraine we've seen the
ukrainians will not be victims they're
going to fight for their country and
it's why we all support them in every
way we possibly can I think there's
tremendous support here and there's
tremendous support in America to get to
the end here this can end
if Vladimir Putin pulls his troops out
the deputy is actually just quickly to
follow up on that
um president zielinski's made it really
clear that territorial integrity means
Crimea which was annexed in 2014 being
returned to Ukraine just to be clear the
U.S would support that we support
President zolensky we support the
Ukrainian people it's not for us to
decide what any negotiated solution
would be at the end it is really up to
the ukrainians do you see the War ending
next year are you hopeful for that I'm
hopeful the war ends as quickly as
possible I think everybody does I think
Ukrainian people want the war to end
they are the ones who have suffered so
enormously just imagine the loss of life
the loss of infrastructure the loss of
whole Villages and towns and cities and
Deputy it's actually if Putin isn't
scary enough Iran's nuclear Ambitions
continue to grow you negotiated the Euro
around nuclear under President Obama
President Biden promised to revive it it
hasn't happened instead Iran has
enriched more uranium than ever before
and elected a hard-line new president
Israel is Iran closer to a nuclear bomb
than it's ever been
we're in a very tough Place The Joint
comprehensive plan of action is still on
the table but it's unfortunately not on
the agenda right now because one the
Iranians really did not take the very
good deal that was on the table
negotiated by the P3 by the Europeans
with the United States in another hotel
during it and indeed we've seen a
protests in Iran we have seen Iran give
uavs to Russia to prosecute this
unprovoked and premeditated invasion of
a sovereign country Ukraine so there is
a lot going on right now we also have
detained Americans who are wrongfully
detained in Iran that we are trying to
get home to their families a lot going
on here
what about the regime we've had
widespread reports we've seen it about
protests and brutal repression
diplomatic sources are telling Sky News
they believe the regime is finished it's
just a question of time before it goes
is that your reading of the situation
too I really am the situation is
certainly that the people of Iran have
said they have had enough
that they want a different way forward
that is for them to decide not for
Outsiders to decide we want to support
those who are protesting in every way we
can so that they can make their own
choice about their own future and just
finally the special relationship the
British prime minister made a foreign
policy speech last week and said nothing
about the special relationship isn't it
the truth that when the British pre-p
prime minister who normally likes to
trumpet this forgets to mention the
special relationship then it's probably
a concept that's had its day now what I
think it says is we are who we are with
each other here we do not need to
continue to name it even though I've
mentioned it today because it just is
we are have such a deep history with
each other we have such a an alliance
with each other and you know when
President Biden became president one of
the things he said he was going to do
was really put a focus on alliances and
Partnerships because nothing in this
world can be done by yourself even if
America leads On Any Given issue we
cannot do it alone we will always be
doing it with others and we will always
have Great Britain with us side by side
hand in hand just quickly is it easier
with the new prime minister Rishi sunak
than it was with Boris Johnson or Liz
truss for President Biden we are very
delighted to have your prime minister
and look forward to working with him
he's just getting started we have a lot
of good work we're going to do ahead now
we're complete now so I'm going to push
my luck if I made one final question
Donald Trump is run in 2024 can
President Biden really repel that
challenge and push on into a second term
when he will be in his mid-80s well
that'll be a decision that President
Biden will make and the American people
will ultimately decide on the president
I work for President Biden I'm a strong
supporter of his I will say that if you
look at our midterm election you will
see that a lot of folks who had denied
the outcome of our last election lost so
I think the American people are speaking
about the kind of future they want and I
was in Mexico City the day after our
election everybody asked me what I
thought about the winners and losers and
I said the winner was democracy
democracy won on our election day
because we had a smooth free open
transparent and solid election you'd
like him to run though I get I'm
gathering you'd like him
okay
thank you so much thank you so much for
joining us on Sky used today thank you
thank you